when the sussexes announced that they
were going to be standing down as
senior members of the royal family and
leaving britain
we were told that they would be dividing
their time between
america and the uk they do still have
frogmore as their
permanent uk base but i i can't see them
equally dividing the year between
america and britain i think
netflix is going to keep them busy they
have found their forever home
in santa barbara america is their new
life yes they will come back to the uk
of course they will want to see
harry's family over here i can see them
coming back and
and spending part of the summer holiday
over here possibly alternating
christmases
but i don't think they're going to be
dividing their time i think they have
made their new life in america
and that is where they will spend the
majority of their time from now on
up until now really the couple have just
been settling
in to their home and they haven't really
strayed too far away but they are untold
beginning to explore their neighbourhood
and they have ventured out
and they've been spotted out and about i
mean they are keeping a low profile
they're very
aware of the paparazzi they're very
determined not to be photographed and
particularly for archie
not to be photographed by the paparazzi
megan and harry have obviously been
making a commute between
la and santa barbara on a relative basis
and
they often stop at the in and out burger
bar
much to the astonishment of the staff
who serve them
and anyone that knows prince harry knows
that he loves
a good burger but i think it has come as
quite a shock to some of the staff who
were serving him
i think it was very much a joint
decision to move to montecito
and it took them a while to find the
house and
harry was very keen to be in a
neighborhood where they could largely
have an
outdoors lifestyle and he loves being
out in nature
as does megan and it was very important
to them that archie was able to enjoy an
ordinary childhood and while they are
arguably
montecito's most famous residents and
it's it's a small community
it's a very private community where
they're going to be very well protected
and i think that is
illustrated by the fact that they've
been living there for two months nearly
now
and haven't yet been photographed and
that's the way they want to keep it they
are exploring the area
and they have met up with neighbors and
friends there but they haven't been
photographed they've been very careful
about keeping below the radar so i'm
told that the house is still
a work in progress it's a big property
um
and we know that megan has a great eye
for interior design
and she was very much involved with
designing their house in the cox world
and of course
frogmore house and so i expect that she
will be involved with the interior
design
and they're in their new home and i
think it's coming on slowly but surely
but we did get
a little glimpse into her sense of style
um when during a zoo meeting part of a
print um was featured in that footage
which showed
some of the interior decor it's a print
that every californian will recognize
and you know megan is the californian
girl
and she's very proud of her heritage
she's very proud of her home don't
forget she has the state emblem of
poppies embroidered
in her wedding dress so i don't think
it's any great surprise to see that
print in the background but it might
just have been a nod to us here in
britain that she is
very firmly back home and very happy to
be there